Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Elise LECAMP
Nous sommes le 12 mars 1977
à Fort-de-France en Martinique.
C'est le jour de ma naissance.
Je suis Judicael.
J'ai 11 doigts
et de la peau entre les doigts,
mes pieds sont déformés,
mes bras sont plus courts que la normale,
et mon visage présente les symptômes
du syndrome Rubinstein-Taybi.
Face à ma différence et pour x raisons,
mes parents m'abandonnent.
Orphelin, à la pouponnière,
un 24 décembre 1977,
une puéricultrice de garde
me prit dans ses bras,
me regarde, et je prononce
mon premier mot : « Maman ».
Depuis ce jour, on me donne une étoile
et prie que celle-ci
me protège toute ma vie.
Naturellement, elle devient ma marraine.
Durant les 4 premières années de ma vie,
je suis ballotté entre
la résidence de ma marraine,
l'orphelinat et les hôpitaux
pour y subir des opérations
afin de rendre fonctionnels
mes bras et mes mains.
En 1981, j'ai 4 ans.
Je me souviens,
j'ai à ma main droite un ballon rouge.
Et à ma main gauche,
je tiens la main de l'assistante sociale
qui m'accompagne à l'aéroport de Paris.
Et soudain,
elle se met à ma hauteur,
me regarde, et m'annonce :
« Judicael, je te présente
tes nouveaux parents. »
Je deviens alors Philippe Ribière
et vis mon deuxième abandon.
Désorienté, et après un long voyage
au sud de la France,
à ma nouvelle résidence,
je découvre une grande famille
composée de 4 filles, 2 garçons
et mes 2 parents adoptifs.
Et je me rends bien compte
que je vais passer ma vie
dans cette famille,
où les enfants
n'ont pas le droit à la parole.
Alors ce soir,
je partage ma vie avec vous,
mais je ne la considère pas
plus ou moins douloureuse que la vôtre.
Il me semble plutôt qu'il était écrit
que je devais naître dans la souffrance,
pour savourer la valeur
d'une vie qui s'émerveille,
qui respire,
(bruits parasites du micro)
et qui se construit.
Alors ce soir,
je partage ma vie avec vous
mais je ne la considère pas
plus ou moins douloureuse que la vôtre.
Il me semble, plutôt, qu'il était écrit
que je devais naître dans la souffrance
pour savourer la valeur d'une vie.
Une vie qui respire,
une vie qui s'émerveille,
mais surtout une vie qui se construit.
Être né sans rien,
je ne pouvais que m'élever.
A l'école, j'apprends à lire,
je dessine, je cours,
je ris, je pleure,
comme n'importe quel enfant,
et bizarrement,
je comprends que je serai toujours
différent aux yeux des autres.
En 6ème, je me souviens,
un camarade de classe s'est moqué
vulgairement à propos de mes mains.
Je le tape au visage
avec ma main gauche,
celle avec la bosse.
Hop, tout droit chez le proviseur.
Et même si j'ai trouvé injuste
son sermon à mon égard,
je me souviens, mine de rien,
d'une petite phrase,
qui me suit depuis toujours.
« On ne résout rien dans la violence. »
Je suis puni, mais pas l'autre élève,
et à mon retour,
ce camarade de classe vient s'excuser
auprès de moi, alors je lui pardonne.
Comme par exemple,
durant mes études,
à la recherche d'un stage en entreprise,
certains chefs d'entreprise
me ferment la porte au nez en prétextant
préférer payer une amende
plutôt que d'avoir un handicapé
dans son entreprise.
Quelle finesse !
Et à 18 ans, pour bien marquer le coup,
je reçois un acte stipulant noir sur blanc
que je suis handicapé de 3ème catégorie.
« Oh, merci de me le dire !
Je ne l'avais pas remarqué ! »
Je suis étiqueté à vie
comme handicapé !
Alors ce jour-là, ma vie bascule
et me pose des problèmes existentiels.
Je ne sais plus qui je suis,
ni où je vais.
J'ai l'impression d'être mal compris,
d'être mal aimé.
D'être handicapé
signifie-t-il d'être incompétent ?
Insensible ?
Je ne me souviens pas
que l'on m'ait nommé une seule fois
« L'handicapé !»
C'est quand même réducteur, non ?
Mais bon. Donc, je suis handicapé.
C'est dur, hein ?
Et ces deux expériences
m'amènent petit à petit
vers le chemin de ma liberté.
J'ai vraiment alors compris
que le sens de mon histoire
est d'être le maître de ma vie.
Alors plus personne
ne se moquera plus jamais de moi !
Plus personne ne me dira
comment agir ou penser !
J'ai le droit au respect et
à la dignité.
J'ai tout simplement lu le premier article
des Droits Universels de l'Homme, qui dit:
« Tous les êtres
naissent libres et égaux. »
Je prends ma liberté.
En 1994, je découvre l'escalade.
Alors, tant que je ne peux rien changer
à mon corps, je fais avec ce que j'ai.
Dans mes bras, je n'ai pas de force,
alors, comment puis-je faire ?
Dans l'escalade, ce n'est surtout pas
une question de force,
mais surtout une question de technique,
d'équilibre,
de compréhension de son corps
face au rocher,
tout en forçant le moins possible.
Je compare souvent l'escalade
à une chorégraphie.
Se sentir dans ses mouvements, dans ses
jambes, dans ses bras, dans ses muscles.
J'aime la hauteur, le vide, le vent,
le soleil, la solitude,
la force, le mental
qui m'amène à ce sommet.
Et toutes ces ascensions
sont toujours différentes
et reflètent parfois l'état
de notre santé mentale.
Parfois, on ne se sent pas bien
à cause de nos problèmes affectifs
et professionnels,
alors nos mouvements se feront hésitants,
et on peut chuter
et se faire mal !
Ou alors,
on aime sa femme, sa famille,
son boulot, etc...
Alors nos mouvements
se feront sans forcer,
en légèreté, tout en forçant
le moins possible,
et à la fin, nous donnera
la plus grande satisfaction.
Et ces capacités de décision
me servent tous les jours
dans ma vie affective
et professionnelle.
L'escalade, c'est pour moi
le premier endroit où je peux
me mettre en manches courtes,
et ne plus cacher,
en été comme en hiver,
sous de longues manches,
la différence.
L'escalade, c'est une façon pour moi
de vous dire que je pouvais faire
les mêmes choses que vous,
et parfois mieux !
(Rires)
L'escalade m'a permis de
me faire confiance !
En 2002, j'apprends que l'escalade
veut devenir un sport olympique.
Qui dit olympique dit paralympique.
Donc, je deviens le pionnier naturel
de la création de la catégorie Handi
auprès de la fédération internationale.
Et je prends le risque de me déplacer
sur des événements ou des compétitions,
tout en ayant le minimum d'argent,
grâce aux allocations d'adulte handicapé.
Et cette même année,
je fais une démonstration lors des
championnats du monde à Chamonix,
et je rencontre, par coïncidence,
la plus grande entreprise
de matériel d'escalade
qui me démarche pour me recruter.
Je rentre chez moi,
gonflé à bloc,
et je me dis :
« Philippe, t'as le meilleur sponsor !
Tes amis t'encouragent et tu as le temps.
Pourquoi ne pas créer un événement
pour les grimpeurs handicapés ? »
En 2003, je crée le premier
événement « Handigrimpe »,
pour faire grimper
les grimpeurs handicapés
et les personnes valides
avec un petit handicap artificiel.
Yeux bandés, mains ou pieds attachés,
pour qu'ils aient peut-être
un petit aperçu
de ce que pourrait être un accident,
un handicap après un accident de voiture,
de moto, un accident vasculaire,
un cancer, etc...
Et échanger avec ces sportifs
m'a bien fait comprendre
que j'ai mes 2 jambes,
mes 2 bras, mes 2 yeux,
mes oreilles, ma langue,
et mon cerveau.
Et qu'à la fin, d'autres personnes
sont beaucoup plus handicapées que moi !
Je ne me plains pas,
et je revois mes problèmes existentiels
dans le bon contexte,
et je réalise que je marche,
je suis champion d'escalade,
et je suis en bonne santé !
En créant cet événement, j'aide
les autres tout en m'aidant moi-même.
Pourquoi sommes-nous
envieux de ce que nous avons déjà ?
Un corps vivant que
la nature nous a donné.
Alors, en 2009, je décide de voyager,
seul,
à travers l'Europe dans un camion.
Et je veux savoir
comment le thème du handicap est abordé
dans les autres pays européens.
Et je veux savoir si la France est en
retard ou pas en matière de ce sujet.
Mais j'ai aussi soif de connaissances,
de ma personnalité
et de mon but dans la vie.
Alors, je grimpe tous les jours
sur tous les rochers européens.
Je donne des conférences dans
les salles d'escalade.
On m'invite même
dans les ambassades françaises.
(Rires)
Je dors seul dans les forêts,
où parfois je mets la musique à fond.
Je danse, je crie, je ris, je vis !
Je vis !
Et lors de ce tour d'Europe,
je me rends compte d'un fait qui me fait
changer ma vision de mon handicap,
et de le rendre beau !
Pourquoi devrais-je être parfait ?
Pourquoi devrions-nous être parfaits ?
Dans la nature, comme dans l'art,
rien n'est parfait.
On aime la différence dans la musique,
dans la mode, dans la sculpture,
dans le dessin, etc...
Parfois nous y dépensons
des sommes énormes...
Pourquoi avons-nous
un problème avec les déficiences physiques
et/ou déficiences morales ?
La nature nous a fait le cadeau de la vie
et nous discriminons
les handicapés, les gros, les petits,
les noirs, les arabes,
un avec un nez comme-ci,
d'autres avec des cheveux
comme cela, etc...
Sommes-nous des modèles de perfection,
nous, les humains ?
Je m'appelle Philippe Ribière
et je me tiens devant vous ce soir.
Certains me considèrent encore
comme une personne handicapée,
et je ne peux rien changer à cela.
Mon corps est mon costume unique.
Mon meilleur cadeau.
Une chance. Une différence. Un art.
Et un outil de travail.
Je suis champion d'escalade.
Je suis libre de mes mouvements.
J'ai du respect, j'ai de l'amitié,
et j'ai de l'amour.
Et tout cela, je l'ai réalisé
grâce et avec vous !
Car vous m'aidez tous les jours
par les petites choses de la vie.
Un regard, un sourire,
une petite blague,
une parole attentionnée,
un toucher à l'épaule,
un baiser.
Mon cadeau, ce soir,
est de vous dire :
merci.
(Applaudissements)